la parole d'allah merci monsieur le
président ce ministre à vis de vous
revoir plusieurs sujets d'abord quelques
remarques selon les interventions des
uns et des autres vous avez évoqué la
question des petites lignes ferroviaires
certes mais on n'a jamais
d'interlocuteurs je crois qu'on a un
vrai souci d'ailleurs je vous ai écrit à
quelques mois pour vous lisez auquel le
cas d'une situation dans le département
je suis élu on n'a pas d'interlocuteur
avec ce qu'on appelait avant rff le
budget qu'évoquer collègue olivier
jacquin sur les ponts destiné aux
petites collectivités 60 millions
d'euros même si on y va sur 100
départements
en prenant cette unité de comptage ça
fait six cent mille euros concept
combien de centaines d'ouvragés d'art
une collectivité départementale a dans
son patrimoine vous doutez bien que ça
ça interroge alors de sujets essentiels
vous serez pas surpris
vous avez vous même évoqué monsieur le
ministre c'est per d'abord les contrats
de plan état région avec ceux qui sont
en cours c'est à dire ceux qui font 2015
2020 la loi prévoyait une clause de
revoyure en 2018 on l'attend toujours
donc quand sera-t-il comment allons-nous
avoir un volet mobilité dans le prochain
contrat de plan etat-région ça me semble
essentiel parce que pour oublier que la
france est encore à 85% rural que le
vélo est donc pas une solution à tous
qu'on a encore besoin de nos routes
nationales gens très présent à l'esprit
mais vous le savez parce qu'on partage
cette géographie la la 147 et la 149 la
147 c'est poitiers limoges
on en parle depuis un premier rapport
qui date de 1954 quand est-ce qu'on s'y
met et puis
l'aérien alors effectivement suivi des
propos de notre collègue à porter est
venu vers moi je suis très demandeurs
d'un travail vous dites qu'il ya une
cartographie qui va est évoquée
notamment sur les dessertes aériennes
aériennes et les rien et l'aménagement
du territoire je pense qu'il ya un vrai
travail à faire sur les aéroports
régionaux ou les aéroports de proximité
ils sont essentiels ils sont essentiels
parce que d'ailleurs on l'a prouvé la
quand tous les jours il y a des
transports sanitaires d'urgence pour
pouvoir réussir ses transports
sanitaires
il faut que tous ces aéroports de
deuxième ou troisième rang comme on dit
soit toujours h/24 et pour qu'ils soient
jointes 4 ça nécessite évidemment un
entretien d'investissement un maintien
par les collectivités
parfois régional parfois départementale
parfois même local donc ils sont
indispensables dans quelles conditions
vous imaginez effectivement qu'on puisse
les maintenir et puis il ya un enjeu
environnemental aussi autour du maintien
de ces héros proximité un aéroport je
prends le pardon on prend l'exemple de
celui que je connais le mieux celui de
poitiers les report pourrait-il temps de
roulage ces six minutes
si on ferme ses aéroports avec
l'argument qu'on concentre tous demain à
bordeaux
aujourd'hui le temps de roulage moyens à
bordeaux ces 25 minutes orly ces 40
minutes
dire que l'effet carbone comme
maintenant il faut avoir cette phrase en
tout le paragraphe l'effet carmon il est
effectivement contre-productif donc
j'attends vraiment le play de vos
positions moi je suis demandeur ne
participe à vous ou vos qu'un groupe de
travail
en tout cas sur les aéroports régionaux
les dessertes les cartographies c'est
essentiel en matière d'aménagement du
territoire et nous l'avons prouvé ce
sont aussi des enjeux économiques il ya
derrière des centaines d'emplois et ce
sont des enjeux sanitaires c'est ce qui
a permis de sauter des sauvé des
centaines de vies depuis le mois d'avril